in this edition lechuck an unusual rally
through Britain the XF Sportbrake
Jaguars new station wagon and the audi
a3 convertible
hitting the German market at the start
of the new year Audi's new a3
convertible brings greetings from summer
to the depths of winter the new model is
based on the two-door sedan instead of
the short three door that makes this
little guy a good 20 centimetres longer
so not a mine stagnant car test across
needs of it says you notice immediately
that Audi has changed a lot in this new
model it's bigger which means passengers
in front and back have a little more
room but you don't want to be too tall
if you're in the backseat to go besides
Austin
words like sleek and elegant come to
mind the bigger wheelbase adds leg space
and back as always a single-frame grille
dominates the car's front it's flanked
by optional LED headlights the car's
rear also recalls its sedan origins with
its muscular design the Audi a3
convertible is a convincing package a
shoulder line that runs toward the back
adds a touch of elegance for Dino hard
like a late howdies dummies along says
the car maker wanted more sportiness in
the new a3 ragtop a car even closer to
the road much flatter much broader and
with added elegance to the shelf though
that's all last but not least there's
the added length which audi has
stretched way out this time yeah I did
howdy now offers a choice of three
engines for the a3 convertible to direct
injection gasoline engines with 1.4 and
1.8 liters there's also a 2-liter turbo
diesel and soon a 1.6 liter TDI hits the
market for the more economy minded add
if you want more power there's the s3
convertible
the 2-liter TDI we tested generates 110
kilowatts of power it officially uses
four point two liters of fuel per
hundred kilometers goes from zero to one
hundred and eight point nine seconds and
has a peak speed of 224 km/h
he's coming off a loss remembers a time
when convertibles were an adventure to
control while driving Crossing railroad
tracks or speed bumps always sent the
steering wheel spinning but this is a
completely different story the car is
practically stiff and handles just
beautifully there's still a slight
understeer but you never feel insecure
not even driving fast into occur theft
in snugga 5 and uncover least the new
convertible keeps its traditional
ragtime but cuts its weight by 50 kilos
for an extra two hundred fifty euros
howdy offers an optional insulated hood
that provides a quieter environment in
just 18 seconds you're under the open
sky and the hood retracts and speeds up
to 50 km/h
timeka think Klaus has one point to
criticize with all four seats occupied
you can't use the wind deflector and
everyone gets the hairdryer treatment
with it elegant lines and clean services
grace the interior
those who extend their top down driving
into autumn weather will love the warm
air vent on their necks it'll be
appreciated on cooler summer evenings
too and thanks to the extended back-end
the sporty four-seater offers 60 litres
more cargo space adding up to two
hundred eighty seven litres total
without flipping over the back seats the
cop Klaus says the Mazda mx-5 launched
the convertible and roast a broom in
1989 many worthy successors have hit the
road sense but in his opinion this one
the a3 without a roof is one of the best
in its class it's the real deal noch
eine owned azhaga the audi a3
convertible sticker price is also a
square deal starting at thirty one
thousand seven hundred euros it's a lot
of car for the money
the lodge a growly starts at Lands End
in the southwest corner of England and
finishes way up on Scotland's north
coast and this year team pink petrol
becomes the first German women's team to
take part in the race
more than 70 vehicles are competing this
year all of the cars have to have been
built before 1984 a technical inspection
is performed to make sure the car is in
its original state the Navigator has to
plot the route using 30 maps an
adventure lies ahead for team pink
petrol the finest doctors like Stephanie
Adel Hoff explains that the lejon the
skills of only the driver or only the
navigator they both have plenty to do
and you can't underestimate the
navigation it's a challenge over the 24
hundred kilometres from start to finish
there are plenty of tests to keep the
team's occupied the winner isn't just
the car that gets to the finish line
first it's the one that collects the
fewest penalty points that requires
savvy and courage and plenty of driving
skill the first test comes right at the
start the others are dotted along the
route under the supervision of helpers
there's a course laid out via the cones
and I have to start at the start line
they go follow a route through the cones
the cones marked hour and it's time from
start to finish the house position I
know event starts until I've got the hat
on once I've got the hat on then we can
start the event which means everything's
in order everything's safe everything's
ready to run what's the problem skipper
we've got problem over there excuse me
second guy sorry the long journey puts
the older vehicles under strain not to
mention the drivers the British weather
can also make it more difficult to make
it to the checkpoints within the time
limits
the teams have to give it their all to
avoid penalty points
Sandra Vukovich says team pink petrol
collected a few points today there was a
special stage and they had to be there
by noon the helpers left it out an extra
eight minutes just for them but they
still missed it by two minutes Alice
teen lesson and give Thomas our light of
it on so I mean you prefer cost
but there's no time to take a break
there are two nite stages that force
drivers to continue into the early hours
of the morning in fact the most exciting
test on the tour takes place in the dark
driving through water is a huge risk
especially for teams driving sports cars
some people change their minds at the
last minute but team pink petrol are
well prepared their Volkswagen iltis
plows through the flood
no sweat for a car like this
the office gets on Stephanie Adel Huff
is thrilled at first she thought what
are we doing here the guy in front of
them bailed out she really wondered if
they pull it off but they did and it's a
great feeling there's even steam coming
out of the car
a glorious sunrise greets the
competitors as they reach the finish
line at John O'Groats just getting here
is something to celebrate pink petrol
and their iltis can be proud
it's a job well done stephanie says they
arrived after a long night and it was a
tough battle through the special stages
but stephanie says it was fantastic
Whitledge AAG it's not all about winning
the journey is what counts
so the team cracks out the champagne to
toast their 50 seventh place finish
with the new rcz r pooja brings its most
powerful mass-produced model ever to the
market powered by a fuel-injected 1.6
litre engine with twin scroll turbo
charging the sports car with it's 199
kilowatts is destined for the road and
the track the world's priciest
Lamborghini is here almost 4 million
euros is what the veneno roadster costs
in Germany worldwide only nine will be
built in 2014 and only without a roof
with its 750 horsepower and 355 km/h top
speed this rarity is mind-blowing to
drive and just to look at
when you think of Jaguar a station wagon
isn't the first thing that comes to mind
the XF Sportbrake could change that all
right song matas carotid car tester is
taking it for a spin he says the
workmanship and materials are all top
notch and there are a few extras that
aren't really necessary but they sure
are fun like these air-conditioning
vents which disappear when the air is
turned off and pop out again when you
turn it back on meet and greet vents in
other words not necessary but nice the
XF Sportbrake is to take on the German
opposition including BMWs 5 Series and
it does just that there's plenty of high
tech and the luxury interior features a
mix of leather and aluminum and lots of
hidden compartments for those who like
that sort of thing the seats are wrapped
in leather of course
we're testing the 2.2 liter 4-cylinder
diesel engine with 147 kilowatts under
the hood it does the sprint to 108 point
five seconds top speed is 225 kilometers
an hour fuel consumption is rated at
just over five litres per 100 kilometers
any time you get behind the wheel of
Jaguar monta says you're looking forward
to a special ride but the XF Sportbrake
doesn't quite live up to those
expectations the 2.2 liter 4-cylinder
diesel engine is quite noisy and has a
raw sound to it the transmission changes
gears constantly looking for the RPM
that will deliver the power that's just
not quite what you expect of a Jaguar
Lincoln tosses need a service each 49 m
yahoo a lot o positive Ella dings on the
plus side though fuel consumption is
quite reasonable at about seven litres
per 100 kilometers and actual driving
conditions on the exterior the sport
break shows what it's made of its sleek
and aggressive with xenon headlights and
a fierce attitude that makes it clear
this car is a predator and just like
inside the exterior sports plenty of
chrome just under 5 meters stem to stern
makes for a roomie trunk it's 510 litres
going up to a capacity of 1635 litres
when the rear seats are down
yes montes has been on the road for a
while now and he says he still hasn't
managed to adjust the seats to give him
a comfortable ride some people will like
them but for Montes the ergonomics don't
work for mr. mussin teases it's the
light on it the suspension does a good
job cushioning the bumps on the road
when it comes to driver assistance
systems the XF is more on the restrained
side there's a rear-view camera a blind
spot monitor ESP and a high beam
assistant and that's it it's good but
not truly top-notch other than I look
all-in-all monta says it's a solid
effort he's got a few bones to pick with
the engine and the seats just aren't
quite to his liking but the Jaguar cuts
a good figure it's comparatively
affordable for a luxury brand and of
course there's the prestige factor
Montes would show out for a more
powerful engine though and better
quality seats if they're an available
option signed off price mr. alcohol
that's not as it's the XF Sportbrake is
listed in Germany for about forty nine
thousand euros standard there's a long
list of options to go along with that
though
our car credit Kristin Bauer is in
wolf's borges car museum looking for an
interesting car to try out of the 200
automotive milestones on display his
attention is drawn to a revolutionary
design that flopped on the market
and as Hughes ro 80 introduced in 1967
the futuristic sedan featured a number
of groundbreaking innovations it was the
first German automobile to win Europe's
car of the year award with him oh Cristo
says NSU which until then had only made
small cars built the RO 80 as a
full-fledged attempt at an up-market
midsize car it had a rotary engine a
futuristic design front-wheel drive
fully independent suspension and disc
brakes on each wheel all the ingredients
for success it seemed NSU's marketing
campaign invited comparison with the
established players here a proud new
owner tells us friendly car has amazing
aerodynamics NSU gambled that the rotary
engine and advanced aerodynamics would
be enough to challenge Mercedes and BMW
the advantages of the rotary piston
engine are that it produces very little
vibration and has good revving power
unfortunately the engine also had
chronic problems many owners had to
replace engines after less than 20,000
kilometers because it's krista says
people used to joke that drivers had a
special greeting to show how many
engines their car had already gone
through and in fact the engine did
initially have bugs NSU had to replace
so many for free that the company's
accountants were in shock but by 1970
the engine problems had been solved this
car from 1977 still pretty sweetly with
its original engine a list of dead yes
that more time
rotary engines get their power from high
engine speed instead of engine size the
RO atntion displaced just one liter but
produced 115 horsepower and had a top
speed of 180 kilometers an hour this 45
year old car feels almost as civilized
as a modern car well almost it's dustin
off the puff t as I a loud bang from the
exhaust leads Christophe to remark that
this car seems to think it's a rocket he
says that although it's not especially
sporty it is a great looking car
features like the low wedge like shape
and sharply raked windshield which is
great for the aerodynamics catch the eye
but the most distinctive touch for
Christoph is this crease that goes all
the way around the car and gives it a
tidy elegance that tidiness ends under
the hood however where a nest of pipes
and hoses hides the little rotary engine
on inwood Owenton does it stuff that can
t vonc a motor the smooth body shape
gave the car a drag coefficient of 0
point 35 which was sensational at the
time and better than that of a
modern-day audi r8 sports car
the interior is straightforward and
unpretentious an automatic transmission
power steering and the big cushy seats
make it a comfortable car for longer
trips the engine is mounted low which
gives the car a low center of gravity
and makes the aerodynamic shape possible
but there's one other problem rotary
engines in general are not very
fuel-efficient and tooling around these
country roads and Tuscany the RO 80
burns up 17 liters of gasoline for every
100 kilometers the transmission doesn't
help
decided by the PR 0 ad has a semi
automatic transmission there's no clutch
pedal so the driver just moves the
gearshift to change gears Christophe
says that takes some getting used to but
it works fine the only problem is the
automatic shift slowly and there's not
much torque so even with 115 horsepower
it's not a very sporty car caught solid
15 past michelada and a swath of
yuengling that accelerating from 0 to
100 takes about 14 seconds which wasn't
bad for a sedan in the late 60s but the
rotary engines performance makes driving
the car a fairly unexcited endeavour
instead the RO 80 feels sedate and
distinguished
evidence Anita humph it's not easy being
a revolutionary Christophe says that
while the ROA t was a failure at the
time it's futuristic design and the
rotary engine make it one of the most
advanced cars of the 60s for our tester
and marks a milestone and the
development of the modern automobile
hobbyist
you